four astronauts are scheduled to blast
off from the kennedy space center
to the international space station this
weekend the joint spacex nasa mission
called
crew one is set for liftoff from florida
at 7
49 p.m eastern time tomorrow here's a
look at launch pad 39a
at kennedy space center this morning
this mission will mark the start of
regular crew rotation flights to the iss
using american-made commercial
spacecraft
mark strossman is there mark how's it
looking
good morning anthony take a look at this
as i was looking at a much closer look
now at the rocket sitting on legendary
launch pad 39a
home to apollo liftoffs to space shuttle
launches and now the spacex era
for the company all the test flights are
over this is the first
regular operational flight to carry
people into space
take a look now that's the falcon 9
rocket behind me on top is the crude
dragon capsule
and with this flight spacex could
solidify its place
in this new commercial era of space
commander michael hopkins and his crew
arrived in florida by
charter jet they plan to depart tomorrow
by rocket ship
we're starting this new era where we're
going to rotate crews to the
international space station from
american soils with our commercial
partners like spacex
and so we're very excited uh to be a
part of that
ignition liftoff of the falcon 9 and
crew dragon
go nasa go spacex godspeed
bottom dog their mission follows this
summer's successful demonstration
flight of crew dragon spacex's new ship
america no longer needs the russians to
get to the space station
even though we've had the demonstration
mission and this is a certified
vehicle at this point we're still going
to be doing a lot of firsts crew dragon
will carry four astronauts its first
full flight more astronauts means more
science
aboard the 100 billion dollar orbiting
lab
astronauts hopkins shannon walker and
soichi naguchi of japan
are all space flight veterans pilot
victor glover
is the rookie every single bit of the
mission
it'll be the first time i've been able
to do that thing in space just getting
up in the middle of the night to go to
the bathroom i don't know
every piece of the mission is going to
be the first time i get to do something
in space
do not latch and the imb is closed
glover is 44.
the former navy pilot is the father of
four girls
in the lab's 20-year history he'll
become the first
black astronaut to stay for a long
duration mission
does that mean something to you i will
once i get there
i try not to think about that too much i
think it is important for our astronaut
corps and the accomplishments of our
agency to represent
the beautiful variety in this country
and so it is important to have kids who
look like me or look like i looked when
i was younger
see someone that they can relate to that
way
on thursday in tesla's the crew
rehearsed their drive to the launch pad
the road to any lodge is long and hard
kovat 19 made this one harder
that's why the crew named their
spaceship resilience
it just felt right it's been a tough
year for everybody
for a lot of different reasons and we
felt like
if the name of our vehicle could give a
little
hope a little inspiration put a smile on
people's face
then that is definitely what we wanted
to do and we felt like resilience was
the name that did that
for tomorrow night's launch weather
conditions are considered 70 percent
favorable and for nasa and for spacex
this six-month mission and this moment
are what they've been aiming for
all along tony which is the start of
regular scheduled
crude missions between florida and the
space station
that's a very big deal mark thank you
very much and we like victor don't we
we like victor very much he's the
ultimate girl dad it seems and i think
resilience family very beautiful i love
how how compartmentalized astronauts are
you asking a question like we'll think
about that
tomorrow but right now we're thinking
about this i'll feel that when i get
there but i just think resilience is
such a great word
in all things really we've needed that
more than anything yeah you're right
blast off for resilience